bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale la
leçon avec comme présentateur
aujourd'hui stéphane laborde bonjour
stéphane alors bonjour donc diaconat la
leçon spéciale aujourd'hui le thème
l'opposition alors et loi qu'est ce que
c'est que l'opposition alors
l'opposition nous en avons déjà parlé
c'est donc un thème qui revient
fréquemment dans les finales de pions et
alors l'opposition ça consiste à mettre
son roi en face du roi et demi pour
gagner du terrain
alors ça c'est donc c'est un thème qui
viennent les finales dans les finales de
pions notamment donc ou du roi sont les
seules pièces active dix ans à part les
pions voilà c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'il y a opposition en finale option
principalement puisque le roi donc étant
la seule pièce restantes sur l'échiquier
on peut avoir ce qu'on appelle
l'opposition alors ça vient justement du
mouvement du roi qui se déplacent tout
une case par une case
donc quand on met notre roi en face du
roi et demi on comprend ce qu'on appelle
l'opposition on en a déjà parlé c'est à
dire qu'on va l'obliger à jouer un coup
et a cédé du terrain ça c'est toute
l'idée donc l'opposition qu'est ce que
c'est en gros c'est un thème c'est une
technique en fait deux finales qui
permet soit de gagner du terrain soit de
dalé soit à gauche ou à droite m c'est
donc en résumé si je commets ses maîtres
le roi en face et j'oublie je les y
oblige les noirs à jouer en fait c'est
ça je l'aimé ce qu'on appelle un besoin
oui enfin là on est obligé de jouer un
coup qu'il faut qu'il va pas être bon
c'est dire que je vais être obligé de
m'éloigner de du lieu de bataille
voilà alors l'opposition
particulièrement efficace quand on a
deux objectifs à gauche et à droite on
l'obligeait à choisir son côté de
défense et on va de l'autre côté ça
c'est c'est une des utilisations et y en
a d'autres donc je propose tout de suite
qu'on voit un premier exemple alors
dernière et la danse allons-y alors donc
tu nous a concocté un premier exemple
simple un exemple très simple
donc on voit de roi en droit à 5 pour
les blancs un rond un g7 pour les noirs
et donc un fief 4 pour les blancs rien
pour 9,5 pour les noirs alors qu'est ce
qui va se passer dans cette position
les blancs vont essayer de ramasser
naturellement ce pions noirs et vont
donc jouer
roy h 30 angers 5 ils prennent
l'opposition c'est à dire qu'il se mette
face au roi et demi mais tout de suite
ce n'est pas le facteur le plus
important
qu'est ce qui est très important ici
c'est que les noirs doivent jouer un
coup ça c'est clair
et qu'au prochain tous les blancs vont
vraisemblablement manger son pion et
comme on l'a déjà vu dans les finales de
droit et puis on contre rouen donc ce
qui va arriver ici il faudra justement
quand les blancs vont prendre ses pions
noirs prendre nous-mêmes côté noir
l'opposition donc ici la défense est
l'unique défense enfin disons il ya un
mauvais coup et que des défenses il faut
jouer roi f8
on va voir pourquoi nous plus tard
j'aurais tendance à jouer ou à vii
oui tout à fait alors bref ça aurait été
la faute alors c'est ce qu'on va voir
puisque après 3 reprend pions maintenant
ici on n'amène non maintenant le roi sur
la classe des recettes c'est-à-dire
qu'on l'amène en attendant la décaler on
a décalé d'un coup alors si j'avais joué
à vii tout de suite j'aurais été obligé
de partir en fait voilà alors on peut
revenir dans la position dans cette
position là sion jour où à vii
maintenant qui est une autre possibilité
il y reprend pions f5 l'organe noir et
dacia - de jouer c'est la différence
était replacé en noir rejouer donc à moi
alors que tout à l'heure c'est tselem
verse tous à l'heure c'était inverse
donc ici comme les noirs sont obligés de
jouer sans que j'aie de dalé soit gauche
qu'on va envisager ici et de jouer trois
sets
à ce moment là on ferme un g6 ça on a
déjà vu dans la leçon précédente
pourquoi ça gagne puisque maintenant
l'option n'a plus qu'a avancé très
simplement
ici c'est pas bon en revanche en jouant
au premier croate 83.5 est maintenant
aux apps est là on force les blancs à
choisir leur côté avant nous sert qu'en
fait on est enfin de gagner du temps et
la remet donc les noirs ont repris leurs
positions
mais tant que les blancs choisissent de
venir ici on garde l'opposition restant
devant eux
et là on est dans la finale élémentaire
ou action contre rouen on sait faire nul
si on se réfère à la leçon de la semaine
précédente
ouais je peux plus avancer mon roi
devant le pion pour préparer le terrain
à la chute bloqué par le roi et demi
voilà on est si j'amène le pian hauteur
de mon roi je sais que je peux plus
gagner
voilà le canton mais l'option hauteur du
roi c'est à dire tout ça sur la même sur
la même traverse s'est très facilement
nul il suffit de laisser droit devant
les cases où le pion devra avancer et on
va faire nul facilement donc ça c est un
premier exemple on peut revenir sur la
question de départ qui est donc la
suivante ici orages et 5
il ne faut pas jouer roi f7 puisque ça
permet trop blanc de garder l'opposition
il faut jouer le roi f8 les blancs
prennent l'option est maintenant au f 7
et là c'est les noirs qui vont prendre à
leur tour le banquier noires arrivent à
annuler dans ce cas là donc là c'est une
thèmes de position pris par les noirs
pour annuler la partie
voilà alors évidemment ce qui est très
important c'est de maîtriser ça
complètement ce qui fait qu'en partie
rapide ou invite cela on n'a plus trop
le temps de calculer pouvoir jouer
d'instinct au roi fuite et non par wise
est dans cette position donc premier
exemple très très simple on va en voir
un autre qui réfute un peu ce cas là
c'est là on a avancé des pions d'une
case plus non plus aux lauréats lors est
plus proche de la promotion maintenant
on est d'accord
non ça j'aime ça change tout parce qu'on
peut pas jouer les 3 bref neuf voilà
déjà on ne peut pas jouer ça et en plus
de toute façon cette finale est gagnante
puisque quand le roi donc ça c'est en
fait c'est un supplément à la finale roi
puis en réaction contre le roi qu'on
n'avait pas vu la dernière fois qu'il
faut absolument voir ici même si les
noirs où l'opposition quand le pion et
sur la quatrième rangée et bien y'a pas
de problème ça gagne de manière forcée
quel que soit le trait donc ici il ya
aucune différence
les plans donc à jouer rois le 6 donc là
évidemment il faut venir un huit c'est
la défense logique même si ça perd quand
même c'est le bon réflexe apprendre
venir sur cette case là maintenant
pousse ses pions
le roi reste sur les tests de pression
on pousse encore c'est le seul exemple
où le pian peut avancer pour faire là
c'est le contre exemple le roi est objet
quitté un peu la défense de la promotion
pour cette suite dame est ici ça gagne
alors revoyons un peu la différence
c'est que dans cette position on est 6 3
8 les noirs prennent l'opposition mais
malheureusement comme le pion est déjà à
trois casses de promotion ses terres
qu'il est sur la rangée où il se trouve
actuellement il n'y a pas de problème la
finale est gagnante dans tous les cas
quel que soit le joueur qui a trait donc
ça c'est un contre exemple en fait c'est
le contre exemple en fait l'opposition
en défense ne suffit pas puisque les
blancs donc à pousser les pions d'accord
maintenant on va passer à des exemples
un peu plus compliqué un peu plus
parlant celui là alors qu'est ce qu'on
voit ici à se compliquer l'adoption
contre 2 alors effectivement ce qu'on a
dit en début de début d'émission est
très vrai pour qu'il puisse y avoir
opposition il faut que les pions soient
bloqués certes si des mesures ne sont
pas bloquées on peut toujours prendre
l'opposition mais dans le joueur joue un
coup
on sur un terrain autres l'échiquier et
reprend à son tour l'opposition cirque
en fait sous le terme n'est pas que j'ai
joué le roi c'est ça marche que si on
est aussi en a que le roi qui peut jouer
voilà tout à fait c'est ça s'il ya
d'autres pions ailleurs qu'ils peuvent
jouer ça ne marche plus il n'y a plus
d'opposition
alors ici très très important voyons un
peu sa lecture sont bloqués donc
l'objectif pour chacun des camps si on
veut gagner cette position c'est d'aller
chercher jeudi à rennes le pion le plus
éloigné donc pour les blancs le pion au
f5 et pour les noirs le pion manger 3
puisque c'est le seul qu'on pourra
apprendre
évidemment les pions se défendre
mutuellement ans acquis de jouer l'un
d'eux cette position alors dans cette
position c'est au plan de jouer et il y
à un coup gagnant alors que tous les
autres coûts font nul
donc qu'est-ce qui se passe voyons par
exemple le premier coup un mauvais coup
on amène le roi sur la case ces quatre
là on prend pas l'opposition la
proposition donc très vite c'est les
noirs qui vont le faire ils vont mettre
le roi face à notre roi
ils vont le mettre en c6 et là on peut
tout essayer maintenant avec les blancs
il n'a plus rien à faire on n'a plus
aucune chance de passer
après trois des quatre rois des six là
on ne peut pas aller sur la case aux
quatre puisque l option on ne peut pas
monter puisque le roi noir contrôle donc
on revient en c4 il revient à ces 6 et
là vous voyez toujours ce fameux barrage
de trois cases
ils nous empêchent complètement passée
est évidemment si on recule là c'est les
noirs qui peuvent la gagner
voilà ça va permettre au noir d'avancé
enfin là ils ne peuvent toujours pas
gagné mais effectivement ils ont avancé
d'un cran et ils ont toujours gardé
cette opposition puisqu'ils contrôlent
encore les trois cases face au roi nous
croit ces cas n'est pas une bonne option
dans cette position ce n'est pas le bon
bout pour faire attention
le bon coup voilà c'est de prendre
nous-mêmes l'opposition directement avec
roy en d4
alors là tu peuvent faire les noirs ils
ont plusieurs mauvais choix c'est à dire
que ils peuvent aller soit à gauche ou à
droite
bon il faut rester près des pieux en ont
en principe oui alors on va regarder
tout de suite cette solution qui est
perdante immédiatement aura ses six
paires à cause de roi ou cinq en masse
tous les pions et apprend gagne
facilement
on la veut
1 on ramasse les options et là comme on
l'a déjà vu dans une édition précédente
de finale de pions quand on a deux pions
d'options donc en finale depuis hongrois
et d'options contre revoir ça gagne
pratiquement à tous les coups pour ne
pas dire à chaque fois donc ici roissy
ce dernier chaque fois dans la mesure où
le roi noir ne peut pas prendre un pion
directement voilà il faut pas non plus
que les pions soient doublés enfin il ya
ben oui il ya des très très rares
exceptions
enfin si l'étudiant aussi les pressions
soient liés soit suffisamment séparés
nous venons en entreprises du roi noir
ça gagne facilement
voilà oui oui c'est clair donc ici
croisé au ras des quatre jouer au
premier coup le roi noir évidemment
reste près de ses pions et là nous
allons introduire un nouveau concept
celui des cases critique alors pour
prendre ce pion là il y a une règle très
simple il faut réussir à se trouver sur
la colonne ce vacancier sur la rangée
sur la même rangée corruption avec notre
roi donc ici évidemment on va aller sur
la case c5 et la très simple il a donc
c'est bon là on est sur la casse
critique le roi noir ne pas une seconde
et roddick et là la grosse pointe c'est
que les noirs ne peuvent pas prendre
position dans cette position ils ne
peuvent pas jouer cinq semaines en face
à nantes 3 puisqu'il ya le pion au f4
donc ici les noirs ne peuvent pas
reprendre l'opposition et on va voir
qu'il n'y a plus de solution pour eux
pour s'en sortir
par exemple un nom le roi toujours près
des pions va rester près des pions wife
swap 6 roi des six whitney le roi blanc
est en train de contourner complètement
cette formation est on à l'opposition en
plus on à l'opposition le roi noir doit
partir
mettons qu'il vienne angers 7 places
c'est très simple
maintenant il n'y a plus besoin
d'opposition puisqu'on est vraiment trop
proche trop production roissy s'attaque
l'option 3g 6 des fonctions et là on
s'aperçoit qu'on va mettre le roi noir
zigzaguant puisqu'on va jouer trois ou
cinq la case m6 est contrôlé par le roi
la 4g 5 est contrôlé par le pion le roi
noir doit partir il doit bouger
il a donc que des mauvaises options
puisque au coude après on va prendre le
premier pion plus le suivant puis
suivant
et donc on gagne facilement la finale
après on gagne extrêmement facilement
donc ça c'est intéressant on a vu donc
pour prendre nos clients le plus arriéré
faut être sur la même rangée que ce pion
oui ça on l'obtient en prenant une
opposition donc reprenons la finale
depuis le début ici il faut jouer trois
ans de 6 c'est la défense la logique on
amène nos trois ans c'est simple on
s'est mis sur les quinze critiques du
pion le roi noir ne peut pas reprendre
l'opposition il doit reculer alors bon
évidemment il peut aller sur une carte
ça ne changera plus rien à la faire
maintenant puisque la cause est entendue
ici on vient en d5 est absolument aucun
blog possible il ya un an m6 il essaie
de s'accrocher à ces cases proche de son
pion aux jeux roi des six de toute façon
il un problème c'est qu'il n'a pas cette
quinzaine a passé 15 le turf carte est
une véritable épine lui tu prends les
cats g5 et e5 donc ici il n'y a pas le
choix il faut qu'ils déménagent encore
d'une case peut-être en 27
on monte en cinq ans j'ai six et on se
retrouve dans une position similaire
après rossi sont va gagner puis 25 donc
bref reprendre les pressions départ donc
là le coup c'est de prendre nos
positions avec trois des quatre prendre
position à 3 des 4 ce qui nous permet au
coup d'après puisque là les noirs en
choix entre deux côtés de toute façon il
va lâcher soit la case la soie la case
là il va lâcher une de ces d'occase
et une fois qu'on sera mis dessus on
sera sur les cases sur la même rangée
avec l'option noirs et là on va lui
mangeait son pion donc exemple très
simple
ici les blancs gagne donc là donc
donc si je résume donc on prend nos
positions et après on a on obtient une
case critique soit le même rangée sur la
même rangée collections et demi ça
suffit pour ligne ça suffit pour gagner
oui tout à fait d'accord donc est en
tout cas le thème c'est bien
l'opposition
donc les droits face à face et forcer
les noirs à jouer voilà c'est
l'impression qui nous permet de nous
mettre justement sur les quinze
critiques du pion nouvel exemple un peu
plus compliqué celui là donc là vous
voyez on dirait presque le même exemple
c'est presque le même exemple sauf que
j'ai inversé l'option g6 et angers 6 au
lieu d' étrangers 4 et l'option blanc et
et angers 5 au lieu d'être en g3 et là
ça change tout ça change tout ça change
tout pour une raison très simple c'est
que l'option à prendre maintenant il est
ici côté blanc oui le pion à prendre il
est sur l'a6 et manger non plus sur la
5e et ça c'est très très important très
très grave donc là bon ça veut dire donc
si on arrive à mettre le roi sur la 6ème
ranger est ce qu'on pourra gagner voilà
sont mes droits soit si le ronge et on
va gagner tout à fait ça que ça veut
dire
alors ici on va on va donc essayer d'y
aller alors première étape
évidemment ne pas jouer le roi c4
puisque après roissy 6 les noirs
prennent l'opposition donc c'est ce
qu'on a vu maintenant ils ne lâcheront
plus cette opposition est donc aucune
raison de lâcher et on pourra plus
avancé d'une seule case ces emplois plus
prendre une seule colonne une seule
rangée donc au premier coup il faut
évidemment jouer or en c3 dans tout ça
c'est l'opposition viennent le voir ses
seins de sa devient automatique
maintenant c'est l'opposition toute bête
par parra par défaut 30 m face euros par
défaut se mettre face au vent est ici
alors voyons par exemple une défense
noire qui consisterait à jouer roy en 17
donc là évidemment on a infléchi n'aime
pas on continue on garde l'opposition on
se met en d5 toujours face à face avec
ses trois cases là et là on voit que
immédiatement le roi noir est obligé de
nous laisser rentrer dans son camp nous
laisser rentrer soit la sixième manche
et puisqu'il n'a plus le choix
qu'il aille à gauche ou à droite ça sera
pareil maintenant s'il vient ici c'est
cuit puisqu'on joue ça continue re5
on reprend encore l'opposition on
s'approche de vers les pions il dit
reste est maintenant roi des is et là on
arrive et on va arriver à prendre le
pion on est à peu près dans le même
thème que tout à l'heure on s'est mis
sur la rangée du pion on va aller le
ramasser tout simplement il n'y a plus
de défenses c'est le exactement le même
thème en fait on s'est mis en service
sur la rangée du pian et le roi noir non
nous bloquer c'est important ça aussi
c'est très important mais peut être donc
près de notre propre opinion
oui mais ça c'est en fait c'est tout à
fait normal c'est qu'il ya deux pions
face à face on se met sur la rangée du
pion et demi c'est bon c'est bon
justement parce que le pion qui est en
face du pont et demi va contrôler cette
case critiqué la case m6 donc la saga
n'y envoie des si on peut continuer
quelques coups roigé cette recette ou si
c'est pareil maintenant
roanne est roi ici en 9,6 et là on
s'aperçoit que le roi noir n'a plus de
caves
c'est toujours pareil il est donc obligé
de nous laisser l'option ou g6 emprise
et ça ça gagne de manière fort c'est
donc ici gain très très simple dans
cette position trois des quatre rois 17
serait une faute
il faut aller en eux six sont très
importants alors pourquoi ce coût est
très très important c'est parce que les
blancs ne peuvent pas vous dire henri iv
et oui voilà donc ce que l'on soit en
opposition
donc on ne peut pas prendre l'opposition
alors par contre on essaie de gagner du
terrain
on va venir sur la case c5 ouais bah on
gagne du terrain
le roi noir ne peux pas vous dire lui
même prendre l'opposition alors la layan
coup il faut que je faut faire attention
alors là faut faire attention puisque
effectivement si on revient au 17 une
fois de plus les plans prennent le
plessis - trois des cinq dans votre la
position de tête on retrouve la pression
tout à l'heure donc ici il faut pas se
tromper avec les noirs il faut prendre
ce qu'on appelle l'opposition en
diagonale éloigner le précieux en
diagonale on peut dire ça comme ça
c'était un maître leroy e set
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer il ya
une case aussi du roi mais cette fois en
diagonale et ça c'est aussi une
opposition
c'est une position des gones al pourquoi
et bien parce que quel que soit le coup
joué par les blancs c'est à dire si les
blancs viennent soit à gauche soit
devant soit à droite soit ouvrant les
noirs feront linverse ses terres soit à
droite soit en montant à la différence
donc c'est bien
pourtant le roi blanc sera bien sûr la
6e ranger mais on n'est pas assez proche
de notre pays où le roi noir le roi
blanc serait bien soit si manger mais
ici c'est les noirs qui prennent
l'opposition et qui sont eux aussi sur
l'a62 manger
et donc là qui nous empêche d'aller
ramasser son pion aussi ici il ya plus
deux des plus d'échappatoire si on vient
on ces sept on voit qu'on n'avance pas
où ces mêmes les noirs qui peuvent
gagner invention alors oui oui très très
bonne très bonne remarque ici ça serait
possible que le noir gagne dans cette
finale m'enfin non ce serait nulle quand
même mais il faut faire attention il
faut faire attention
ne nous enflammons pas en finale puisque
de toute façon voilà c'est très bien on
voit que tout le monde peut gagner la
finale de pions comme il ya quand même
un matériel qui est égal il n'y a pas un
déficit énorme donc là ce qu'on a vu sur
war c6 les noirs reviennent et sur wade
là nous avons la même position que
précédemment
sauf que c'est aux blancs de jouer et là
ça change tout puisque c'est les blancs
qui ne peuvent ou ne peuvent plus gates
et un houleux que les noirs doivent en
concéder les blancs ne peuvent plus on
gagne et après 3,5 suis bien entendu
revoir cette voie là on garde
l'opposition
si le roi recul le roi avance très
simplement nous qui si je pense que les
flèches sont assez explicites dans cette
position si le roi blanc montrent laura
noir va se mettre en face si le roi
blanc va à droite le roi noir va se
mettre à gauche toujours en face ont
donc ici c'est l'opposition en diagonale
l'opposition éloignées qui gagne
enfin qui fait nul systématiquement qui
feignent systématiquement donc reprenons
encore cet exemple depuis début puisque
idée assez ludique est assez important
premier coup les blancs tente le tout
pour le temps de d'annoncer d'autres en
tout cas on prend la position tout de
suite trois des quatre c'est le c'est la
meilleure façon d'essayer de gagner pour
des quatre propositions roi a eu 6
c'est le seul coup qui fait ce nul
puisque ce roi 17 suivre et trois des
cinq qui prend l'opposition et qui gagne
puisque là on va se mettre sur une des
cases critique du pion enfin pas tout de
suite d'abord ce roi 7 on va encore pour
l'opposition
et là on va y aller voilà parce qu'il
faut prendre la 6e ranger mes proches le
plus proche du pian possible le plus
proche du plus haut possible ça c'est ça
c'est très important
donc voilà roy 17 fautes 3 o6 c'est le
meilleur coût c'est le seul coup même
rossé 5 on essaie quand même d'y aller
et là le couple est le couplet de cette
position c'est la défense avec 3 e set
donc qui prend l'opposition en diagonale
qui empêche les blancs n'a passé et qui
empêche les blancs de passer donc que
ses besoins que insuffisante de côté
noir en fait on arrive à bloquer les
blancs complètement oui oui
donc voilà exemple suivant l'exemple
suivant et dernier exemple pour pour
cette leçon aujourd'hui les blancs on
leur envoie ancêtres par des noirs en
gros en c6 et là on va voir que
l'opposition ne passe plus par les cavs
critique mais simplement par le fait qu
on force le roi noir à choisir s'il part
à gauche ou à droite 1 n'est ce pas oui
tout à fait
donc ici qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et
bien évidemment bien entendu vous l'avez
deviné faut prendre le positif on prend
l'opposition leroy montant c4 le roi
noir a le choix entre rester sur les
côtés de la défense de section ou allait
lancer cette qui sembleraient plus
souple ou partir très loin alors premier
choix wab et si ce qui est le moins
le moins teigneux et on voit tout de
suite on peut naître bonjour trois des
cinq là alors là on est carrément sur la
casse critique puisqu'on va prendre le
pion au coup d'après donc c'est gagnant
croisé 7,3 prend pions et là c'est
gagnant puisque on a ce qu'on appelle un
pion passé éloignés et de toute façon en
fait le pion tout seul en 24 suffirait à
gagner donc y'a papa lé là tu fis
puisqu'on peut on peut veut jouer après
au cours a pris 3,6 voilà et préparer le
chemin pour le pian comme on a vu pour
gagner les finales depuis en tout à fait
donc ici ça serait gagnant très
facilement maintenant mais tant qu'il y
annoncer sets c'est une autre
possibilité mais ça nous laisse
évidemment la même chose avec trois des
cinq ou également avec 3 et 5 c'est au
choix
ici non là par contre on peut voir que
c'est pas si simple que ça parce qu'on
rentre les noirs peuvent prendre
l'opposition et noir peut jouer 3 17
on prendrait de notre du pion il
continue à regarder l'opposition donc là
les noirs l'opposition dans la vue de
tout à l'heure donc ça c'est parti hurle
ça ça c'est une finale nul mais on a vu
également dans le cours de la dernière
fois qu'on a fait un tube assez éloignée
ces terres pierre de combles a qui sont
un rôle très important
d'accord alors est ce qu'on peut
comprendre pourquoi alors on va
comprendre pourquoi on jour où un des
cinq ici pour faire annuler le seul coup
cette garde et l'opposition c'est roy 17
maintenant tous les pions et non
maintenant tout ce peuple on n'est pas
pressé d'avancer spira bon on va d'abord
aller chercher le pion et ni de l'autre
côté et ça c'est le fameux option pas
s'éloigner qui fait diversion et qui
oblige les noirs à revenir dessus
ici il suffit de suivre le roi suivre le
roi est ce qu'on peut pas revenir ses 7
points pour regarder l'opposition oui on
peut garder encore l'opposition mais là
le problème c'est qu'après roye b 5 en
garde l'opposition on garde encore
l'opposition mais comme on l'a dit en
début d'émission
il y a deux pions passé à l'adoption
plus musclée après avoir prouvé
s'inquiète donc là le pression n'est
plus n'est plus vraiment cours ici ce
n'est pas possible c'est à dire qu'après
une fois qu'on aura de plus en plus on
va pousser un pion à droite
et puis si le roi à le chercher au plus
haut point haut à gauche voilà on pourra
pas garder les deux exactement sur le
thème du chiapas et éloignés note
finalement quand on a un pion passé
comme c'est le cas là et qu'on est en
opposition et qui reste des pions de
l'autre côté il faut pas pousser son
pion mais faut les chercher les plans de
notre côté oui c'est à dire que ici la
finale est nul si on essaie d'avancer
notre pions tient essaiera c'est le bio
la nive en hausse et parce qu'on l'a vu
tout à l'heure on l'a vu
il ya des plans à à gauche qu'on peut
aller chercher donc ça fera diversion ça
fait diversion et donc évidemment plus
la diversion est éloigné c'est à dire en
gros le la le pion est très éloigné du
roi noir plus c'est bien c'est à dire
que si notre petit on n'était pas ici
mais l'a déjà dit version serait
beaucoup moins efficace puisque le roi
noir ne me fais d'un coup pour les
prendre l'option alors que la wii 2 en
ce moment il faut trois qu'on pourra le
chercher trois coups pour revenir donc
le temps le temps pour les manger
espions et des très très long donc ici
pas de pas de solution on va chercher
d'autres pions fait diversion à
l'adoption passé et ça gagne très
simplement donc autres nouvelles
possibilités
après trois des cinq oui en dix-sept
donc ça s'appelle sa perte très
simplement
autre possibilité d'impression de départ
on a vu que si le roi fainéant b6 à
perdre et puis ce qu'on allait prendre
le pion aux cinq dans le beh si c'est la
cas ici on va prendre à ce moment là le
pion aux cinq et ont fait dame de
manière fort ça va peut-être voir on va
essayer de recruter parce que peut-être
le braille et ça c'est beaucoup plus
persistants effectivement conflits
persistants puisque maintenant après roy
b5
on peut jouer par exemple 3 c'est cette
lettre est logique
roy prend et au revoir ses 6 alors ici
la méthode de gain va être la même que
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que là on
l'a déjà dit on va leur dire les finales
de pions avec un pion sur la colonne ne
gagne pratiquement jamais sauf s'il
pleut on peut avancer tout ça veut dire
que ce option là tout seul ne gagnera
pas c'est une finale nul si on fait
abstraction des d'options qui sont là
donc seule solution pour gagner c'est la
même chose qu'avant on joue roi b43 b6
et là on n'avance pas plus on pourrait
l'avancé mais on joue ça pour garder la
diversion le plus loin possible
hélas il est noir cherche à garder
l'opposition donc avec roy c6 le coup
qui me permet de la récupérer ces
attaques à cinq récupère l'opposition
faisant diversion tout simplement là il
n'est plus de trop question de position
en fait dans cette finale puisque on
fait là il est question de diversion
principe
le roi doit venir quand même garder
l'option qui menacent d'aller à dame
et là pendant qu'il y va tout de suite
on va de l'autre côté on ramasse le
dernier pion et celui là y'a plus qu'à
l'annoncé c'est une finale
élémentaire hélas le renoir est
complètement d'un vieillard aux fraises
comme on dit pour arrêter le pion voilà
d'autant plus que on va intuitivement du
bon côté c'est à dire du côté qui va
repousser le roi noir on se met sur la
caisse des six après roissy
on avance notre pions il ya plus rien
qui peut l'empêcher d'aller à dame et
donc de gagner cette partie donc royaume
contreras vous savez déjà le faire dans
la leçon on l'a déjà vu plusieurs fois
voilà alors on peut peut-être faire une
conclusion sur cette opposition
oui donc alors moi j'ai compris donc
l'opposition sait mettre les rois face à
face à peut être défaut en diagonale
quand on n'a pas d'autre choix et
suivant les finales de pure alors dans
les finales de pions comme ça des
chaînes de pions
l'idée c'est de prendre le plus en plus
éloignés de la chaîne et de cette
arrivée à se mettre sur la même rangée
que le pion qui défend la chaîne voilà
alors ça c'est les fameuses cases
critiques c'est à dire que y'a un pion
qui est qui défend un autre pion il faut
attaquer l'option défendant et non pas
l'option défendue ça paraîtrait logique
et pour ça il faut se mettre sur la même
rangée que ce pion
c'est les fameuses cases critique et
pour y arriver on se sert du moyen très
simple quelle opposition cirque on va se
mettre face au roi et demi le roi qu'il
va devoir bouger soit à gauche ou à
droite on va aller de l'autre côté on va
le prendre à contre-pied à revers on va
se mettre sur les quatre critiques et
ensuite on va les chercher le pion ça
c'est effectivement c'est une des
utilisations de l'opposition alors quand
on a les rois très éloignées comme ça
par exemple parce que là on a vu des
rois tout proche
donc on a pris l'opposition qui te suit
mais si les revoir sont plus éloignés on
peut calculer est de prendre position
aussi alors ça c'est justement le thème
de la prochaine émission des gones à la
leçon ça va être les cases conjuguer les
casques en juillet c'est une opposition
qui est très très éloignés voire même
pratiquement introuvable c'est une des
fêtes c'est l'élément le plus difficile
à comprendre des finales de pions c'est
une opposition à très très long terme
alors est-ce qu'il faut mettre le roi
ici ou là qu'on le roi et demi est à
l'autre bout de l'échiquier là où là ça
fait des différences ça fait la
différence entre gains ou nuls dans
certaines positions
c'est ce qui en fait c'est une extension
les casse conjugué donc c'est le pourri
résistance voilà c'est ça s'est su à
distance
il ya l'opposition toute bête qui est
roi face à roye l'opposition à distance
qui est donc on a vu diagonale de la
pression des gonades qui est une sorte
de positions éloignées
l'opposition très éloignées qui est par
exemple le roi eu un contre le roi en
1/8 ça on arrive encore à voir en se
référant aux couleurs des cases et les
casse conjugué ça devient très très
compliqué c'est à dire que là les rois
sont n'importe où sur l'échiquier c'est
en fonction de la structure d'options
que ça tu joues et ça sera le thème de
la prochaine émission diagonale la leçon
donc que vous verrez lundi prochain
d'accord il n'y aura que ce thème là où
notre pays aura ce que ce thème là il
est énorme il est très très difficile je
pense qu'on verra un ou deux exemples
tout au plus c'est un thème très
compliqué donc pour conclure sur sa les
finales d'options c'est très simple
revoyez tous et vous je pense que vous
aurez à peu près tout compris à cet
élément clé des seuils très important la
finale de pions et c'est très très
important
il suffit de prendre option au début au
début de la partie vous échangez toute
la pièce si vous savez si ces gagnants
au nul ça fait toute la différence d'où
l'importance d'un pion en fait qu'on
comprend les grands champions qui ont
besoin de plus il gagne est parti c'est
notamment parce qu'elle en finale ne roi
contre roye ils savent comment gagner
oui des fonds du chantage toujours à ses
positions gagnantes font du chantage ses
positions d'anadarko dans l'exposition
hillman à échanger des pièces 6 ans
rentre dans une finale rencontre roy si
on a bien compris tous ces thèmes là on
sait que c'est gagnant ou pas et donc on
peut on pas accepter les changes ou pas
voilà exactement
donc après on fait du chantage et pour
obtenir d'autres positions gagnantes
oui d'accord bon mais très bien je crois
qu'on a fait le tour de l'opposition
donc voilà pour cette c'était que
qu'elle est c'est fait comme une
émission ça doit en faire une dizaine d
hommes 10 m donc voilà donc on se donne
rendez-vous à la semaine prochaine avec
bertrand guyard oui tout à fait l'indien
prochain donc pour une nouvelle leçon
sur les cas seront utiles sur les cages
conjuguée à la semaine prochaine